ken kitchinelli joins us now ken great
to talk to you this morning it's um
you know look it's an incredibly sad
story to talk about a four-year-old
found among not just illegal immigrants
but among smugglers
why is that happening
so
it's a sad story but uh you know this
happens all the time
the
roots that the cartels use and remember
who manages the border it isn't the
federal government of the united states
it's the drug cartels of mexico some of
the most evil vicious people in the
western hemisphere and they run
their human smuggling operation through
the exact same channels that they run
their drug smuggling operation through
and they direct the flows to distract
and move the border patrol around using
people
to try and avoid getting their high
value crossings caught
and to put as many of them over the
border as possible there are some
estimates that the drug cartels are now
making more money
from
human smuggling than from drug smuggling
and no one federal government or states
including texas is doing anything to
stop that flow
i hear you i hear you bringing up texas
let's discuss texas the governor of
texas greg abbott has embarked on his
campaign to send illegal immigrants to
washington d.c i think a third bus has
arrived in washington dc to to
essentially lay the problem
at the feet of the federal government
what do you think of this program
well it's the last leg in a human
smuggling chain that we have been
criticizing the federal government for
doing uh you know the recent articles
about renewing charter flights around
the country of illegals farther in and
now texas is doing it i understand why
you want to drop them in the steps of
the capitol
but
these are voluntary trips they want to
take the trip governor abbott is paying
to bust them 26 hours on a trip they
want to take
instead of bussing them two miles back
across the mexican border which is what
he should be doing and until he does
that let me be really clear about this
until he does that and he does have the
authority to remove people from mexico
to mexico the illegal flow will not go
down so for all the signing with mexican
state governors and so forth who don't
have any authority to stop immigration
across our border it's all a show it is
all a show and you'll see next month
when the numbers come out before title
42 is taken down on may 23rd you will
see that it had no effect at all on the
flow of illegal immigration so ken i
hear you and and i can hear very
specifically you are laying blame not
just at the feet of the federal
government but directly on texas and the
governor of texas greg abbott you are
saying that this is all political
theater
i had here on fox and friends last
weekend both attorney general ken paxton
and lieutenant governor dan patrick on
the program and i asked them about
essentially your accusation before it
was made ken that this is political
theater and both of their response is
the point is
to force a constitutional confrontation
to force the federal government to
confront the fact
they're not enforcing our immigration
laws so texas or someone must in essence
what they're saying and i want to get
your response is this is supposed to
force us to the supreme court on who can
enforce illegal immigration laws
well and ken paxton and dan patrick and
greg abbott all know how to do that and
it isn't bussing people to washington it
is by the governor as the
commander-in-chief of texas forces and
every governor is the commander-in-chief
of their own state's forces
stopping the invasion first of all greg
abbott calling it invasion and i don't
think many people would dispute that's
what's going on
and then repelling that invasion under
article 1 section 10 of the
constitution
if you want to provoke a constitutional
crisis then maybe you should use your
constitutional authority to do it
instead of a bunch of press
gimmicks
and that's what we would urge not just
governor abbott we're talking about
texas but governor ducey over in arizona
as well and his attorney general has
found he has the legal authority to do
this so there's nothing in the way
within his state from acting to defend
the borders of their state and the
united states and to your point if you
want to force a constitutional
confrontation you could do the exact
same thing by removing the illegal
immigrants back to mexico instead of to
washington d.c uh all right ken great
conversation great perspective perhaps
we'll hear
from the politicians in texas in
response thank you for your time this
morning
good to be with you you have a great
easter